well title ix helped shape women's wide
world of sports from high school through
college and to the professionals for
women's sports there isn't a more
important piece of legislation
it was june 23 1972 when a 37 word piece
of legislation paved the way for women
it was called title ix an equality law
that included the word activity meaning
men and women will have equal access to
sports that dollars shouldn't justify
differences yes progress is being made
but equality is not increasing in a
significant way aces guard kelsey plum's
mom play division one volleyball so
she's heard the stories you know when
she played
she was
coached by the softball coach
and the tennis coach like there was one
coach coaching three different teams and
you know they didn't have a weight room
they shared obviously facilities with
everyone they had very limited practice
time according to usa today division one
schools are spending 71 cents on the
women while spending a dollar on the men
so after all these years women are still
being shortchanged making progress
however when it comes to title 9 i look
at and understand and i'm standing on
the shoulders of giants that have laid
the foundation down that have worked so
hard to be able for me to compete at all
three levels high school college and now
pro wnba tv numbers are up the women's
final four numbers are up more people
are paying attention to women's sports
because title ix is changing a culture
my biggest thing is making sure that i
can lay the foundation down and plant
those seeds for the next generation
because we know it's going to take time
to put title 9 in perspective while the
men are rounding third base the women
are just approaching first if a school
has 60 undergraduates who are women they
should get 60 athletic opportunity but
87 percent of the 127 fbs schools aren't
even close to complying a lot of times
we call it equal but it's not equal
[Music]
all right celebrating the 50th
anniversary of title ix well the raider